crank behind its own pawns
a lot of work to be done here will he
find this move i mean he's got 40
seconds espienko and it doesn't look
like he's found it yet just from his
body language yeah i think he's just not
changing from defense to attack as you
mentioned what does white do after this
move i mean he hasn't found it
he hasn't found it no this would have
required white to i think so look at
this move wow okay nice let's uh okay i
was going to say let's go back to the
players but right now white has
sacrificed the queen if the rook takes
this is a deadly check white is about to
emerge with an extra bishop let's go
back to the players we'll explain this
later but white is about to win i think
he has one yeah mr franco gives up he's
about to lose a whole piece for free
napoli actually perfect technique to
finish it off wow this semi-final match
is over after three games janupomniacci
winning game two and now
game three to knock out
nineteen-year-old andre sipenko who has
had a great performance